what you mention the human condition
does love have to do
what role does it play in the human
condition friendship
love
is
the drug
kind is uh this was a great roxy music
line
uh that brian ferry wrote and love is
uh the most powerful and and dangerous
of all the drugs
uh the um
the
driving force that overrides our reason
and of course uh it is the
it is the primal it's the primal urge
so
what a civilized society has to do is to
prevent that drug that primal force from
creating mayhem so there have to be
rules
uh
like monogamy
and
rituals like like marriage that that
reign love in and make the
the addicts
uh
at least
more or less uh under control and i i
think that's
that's part of why i'm i'm a romantic
rather than a you know steve pinker
enlightenment rationalist because
the romantics realized that that love
was the drug
it's like
the difference in sensibility
between uh handel and wagner
and i i had a vagnerian phase when i was
an undergraduate and i still remember
thinking
that in
in uh as old as libras toad
that wagner had got the closest to sex
that anybody had ever got
in in music
or perhaps to love
i'm i'm
lucky that i love my wife and that uh
that we were
by the time we met
you know smart enough to understand
that that love is a drug that you have
to kind of take in in in in certain
careful ways
and that
it works best in
the context of a
of a stable family
that's that's the key thing that one has
to sort of take the drug and then submit
to the
the the conventions of of of marriage
and family life
i
i think in that respect
i'm a kind of
tamed romantic
team romantic that's how i'd like to
think about it and that's the degree to
which your romanticism is tamed can be
then channeled into productive work
that's why you're a historian and a
writer is that love is channeled through
the writing so if you're going to be
addicted to anything be addicted to work
i mean we're all addictive but yeah the
thing about workaholism is that it is
the most productive addiction
and uh
and rather that than than than drugs or
booze so i i'm i'm
yes i'm always trying to channel my
anxieties in into work
i learnt
that at a relatively early age it's a
sort of massively productive way of
coping with the inner demons
and again we should teach kids that
because
let's come back to our earlier
conversation about universities part of
what happens at university is that
adolescents have to overcome all the
inner demons and these include
deep insecurity
about one's appearance about one's
intellect and then
madly raging hormones that cause you to
behave like a complete fool with
the people to whom you're sexually
attracted all of this is going on in the
university how can it be a safe space
it's a completely dangerous space by
definition
yeah so
so yeah teaching young people how to
manage these storms uh
you know that's part of the job and and
we we're really not allowed to do that
anymore because we can't talk about
these things for fear of the title nine
officers kicking down the door and
dragging us off in chains
you